[Laughter]
[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
this is the red hydrogen one
and this this is a really weird phone in
a lot of ways there have been so many
questions about this thing is it really
a 1295 device i knew red cameras were
expensive but why is the phone so
expensive what's so good about it is it
like a red camera in your pocket who is
it for what makes it special what is a
holographic medium machine why does this
exist you got questions i got answers
and i've actually been in the unique
position of not only using the phone for
the past couple months but actually
seeing and following along with the
development of it behind the scenes for
almost as long you guys might remember
the video i did on the early prototype
of the hydrogen back and it was still
somewhat of an idea
i was into it i shared it red wanted to
share with you what they were working on
with the world um but since then a lot
has changed and it's all landed on this
the final retail shipping version of the
red hydrogen one and as it exists it is
the most frustrating phone that i've
bought this year
as a smartphone this thing is pretty
scattered it definitely doesn't resemble
any other phone in pretty much any way
on the outside like it clearly doesn't
fit in with the 2018 glass sandwich
design and notches and actually think
it's perfectly fine being different i
would describe this as more of a modern
industrial look it's a huge phone first
of all it has only a 5.7 inch display
which we'll talk a lot more about in a
bit but it's not the biggest screen out
there but it has the huge bezels around
it there's a giant forehead and a chin
with big speakers in them and we'll also
talk a lot about those
and a pretty serious looking array of
front-facing cameras and sensors and an
led notification light and then the back
is this two-tone look with exposed
carbon fiber and aluminum and just open
seams and ridges and textures
and there's also a lot of text all
around this phone so it looks and feels
industrial and then you have this whole
rubberized side grip which with my hands
is fine the way i hold the phone but
yeah it's basically the opposite of an
iphone as far as build and slipperiness
goes matter of fact here's my little
anti-plug don't put a dbrand skin on it
don't put a case on it it feels like it
already has a case on it it's built like
an absolute tank it turns out that's a
big reason why this phone costs thirteen
hundred dollars these materials the
carbon fiber and metal
but beyond that there's pretty much no
other reason why someone would spend
that much on this phone let's get into
all the other things it's a big phone
like i said and it makes a pretty good
use of that space keeping a headphone
jack up at the top the micro sd card
slot usb c at the bottom and it's
packing a 4
500 milliamp hour battery so the biggest
in any phone i've tested so far no ip
rating yet though but they say they're
working on it probably because of those
exposed pins on the back i'll tweet or
share an update if they do get approved
for ip68 or 67 or something like that
but then on the inside since this
phone's been in development for a year
now it's using specs from a year ago so
snapdragon 835 six gigs of ram 128 gigs
of storage and expandable and that huge
battery so yes you did hear that right i
said snapdragon 835
not snapdragon 845 and to be honest if
you just handed me a phone and asked me
if i could tell if it was the 835 or 845
i probably wouldn't but when you're
spending 1 295
minimum for this phone you kind of
expect the latest and greatest highest
end hardware
and that's not what you're getting here
but to be real the performance is
actually fine as it should be because
there's pretty much no skin or any sort
of heavy customization happening here
i've always said staying near stock
android is great for both performance
and hopefully quick updates so i can
confirm on performance but there's no
word on android p for this phone but
i've gotten maybe seven or eight
software updates since i started testing
pretty much all of them have been camera
related though but yeah basically the
only customization you'll find in the
hydrogen software is this red launcher
which is actually pretty good it feels
like nova launcher and has a lot of
options
and then some ugly custom icons and some
pre-installed apps for holographic
content
but yeah that's why the performance and
battery life are actually good the
software is simple enough and you've got
six gigs of ram okay so this is the part
where we should address the frustrating
part of this phone what is a holographic
medium machine why is that the tagline
for this phone well that's because of
three things
the display
the speakers
and the cameras on this phone they're
all specialized for something called for
view so let's start with the display
it's a 5.7 inch panel like i said lcd
2560 by 1440 so pretty high pixel
density and through normal use in 2d
mode normal mode it seems pretty good
colors and contrast are on point at
first glance viewing angles are good but
i'll get back to that in a second what's
unique is this special mode a glasses
list 3d that works in portrait or
landscape with specially formatted
content for view content
holographic content so don't let the
word holographic fool you that's just
like one of their marketing terms it's
not like there's stuff like floating out
over the display like a hologram no no
no it's it's still a very much what
you'd expect out of a glasses-less 3d
experience it's all on the display
but it's more about depth and it's
sometimes pretty good now obviously
cameras don't show it pretty much at all
so sadly i can't give you this
experience this is kind of the best i
can do but my best attempt at describing
what you should be seeing is it's like
this sort of shimmery trippy
3d depth effect that you can see when
you look at it head on i actually think
when it's used well and content is shot
for four view it's actually pretty good
i've showed this to a couple people and
their reactions have been more or less
impressed when there's content
specifically like i said made for this
format things will sort of pop out of
the screen and appear to fly at you like
a 3d movie it's a good 3d effect it's
fun some content doesn't look good
though especially when it's more flat or
there's less separation between a
foreground and a background or if it's
just poorly converted it just looks like
a sort of a lame pixelated version of
normal footage so it's hit or miss in
this way but like any 3d effect also you
don't really want to look at it for too
long eye fatigue is real hologram me
holographic is the word they use but
it's
it's hard to explain and it's kind of
trippy
whoa
dude this is weird
and there's there's different like so
there's a movie trailer version of it
where there's like things coming towards
you and i think that's maybe the best
use of it i've seen
uh it's impossible to show on camera
i've tried many different times no this
this will never show up on camera this
is yeah but this is odd
[Music]
so it's really strange okay so it has
this cool mode but now as a result you
also have some other downsides of the
display a couple actually the fact that
it works in portrait or landscape is
pretty cool most 3d effects only work
with the display in one orientation but
because of the hardware layer that makes
this possible the brightness
specifically suffers quite a bit so the
hydrogen one screen just does not get
very bright and then in 2d or regular
mode you'll notice it looks
i would describe it as kind of pixelated
and i don't even have to pixel peep very
hard to notice it especially on white
backgrounds that again is because of
that hardware layer this display tech so
the 513 pixels per inch kind of doesn't
mean that much if i'm constantly seeing
what looks like these dots on the screen
all the time look at this side by side
with the pixel 3 display that's a big
difference now the interesting news here
is i asked jim from red about this and
he says that it's a combination of part
hardware
part software and that it can
technically be improved with software
updates and that it used to be worse and
that it's gotten better to the point
that it exists now i i want to believe i
want to believe that it can keep getting
better to the point where it's almost
totally gone
but i don't know but what i'm gonna do
is actually i'll post the entire little
mini interview i did with jim founder of
red
and you can hear exactly what he has to
say for it uh his very pr answers or
whatever but i'll link it right by the
like button if you're interested in
hearing that um but yeah it's it's just
i i can trust my eye about what i
observe and then you can listen to what
he says so that's the display and then
you have these speakers flanking it they
are also optimized for for view now in a
big phone like this like maybe a razer
phone or a pixel 3 i'm bracing myself
for amazing speakers right like they
they have these these huge spaces for
big drivers they're not gonna be easy to
block i'm ready to be really happy with
these speakers pull up some audio
anything music games video whatever and
the speaker on the hydrogen one isn't
even louder than average
[Applause]
this speaker doesn't sound that great i
put the volume all the way up to max and
to be fair it doesn't distort much so
that's an upside but it's also really
lacking and a little bit tinny kind of
sounds like a big weak laptop speaker in
the first place it's a pretty big
letdown to me there is one setting you
can tweak though and it's called 3d
audio and when you toggle it on
it gets even worse now the 3d effect it
creates is actually noticeable so then
you start to hear the left and right
stereo separation the sort of pseudo
surround sound effect that you'd be
similar to hearing on an iphone but it's
not that good and it's even more tinny
now and still not very loud and then on
the back there are those cameras
this was one of the original reasons i
was so excited when i heard red was
making a smartphone like the space was
getting interesting we had the pixel 2
that was kind of the king of cameras for
a while then iphone 10s stepped their
game up and then pixel 3 sort of
expanded their lead we have all these
other cameras with these multiple lenses
and multiple cameras on the front and
the back and then we heard red a
specialty camera maker that i obviously
love was going to step in and make a
smartphone which would have cameras on
it this should be amazing i'm ready for
this and well it turns out these cameras
are
just
they're okay
they're just okay it is dual 12
megapixel cameras in the hump of the
back dual led flash and the cameras are
spaced out far enough apart for depth
detection and i've been sharing actually
photos from hydrogen's camera here and
there for the better part of a couple
months now among multiple software
updates and a rapidly evolving color
science and camera app but here's the
thing to understand red
doesn't make
this camera this is a like an
off-the-shelf camera probably a sony imx
sensor or something like that the same
kind you see in a bunch of other
smartphones so the best that red can do
is what they can get out of this sensor
and their improvements in color science
and hdr and software but reds cameras
like the one i'm using for this video
are so incredible because red is so good
at making the silicon the actual sensor
that's used to shoot and then they
control the entire image processing
pipeline and they make the camera and
the software and everything so they
control the entire end to end but here
with the hydrogen like i said they don't
make these sensors they're just doing
the best they can with off-the-shelf
parts and software so if you are
expecting some sort of extreme red
quality camera built into this
smartphone
that's not what you're getting here
hold that thought until the end so yeah
photos from the hydrogen's built-in
camera are all right they're they're
solid with color and dynamic range i
left hdr turned on the whole time often
reds became a little bit muddy
sharpness was pretty much always good
but photos in general were just hit or
miss basically you have to give it a lot
of light and it'll do fine but things
start to fall apart in less than ideal
conditions this isn't drastically better
or worse than something i'd expect out
of like a oneplus 6t and obviously
software updates will continue to make
tweaks and adjustments over time but
that's just where we're at now of course
red is mostly known for their video
cameras so how good is the 4k video here
again with the built-in stuff pretty
good but nothing exceptional or
unbelievable again think oneplus 6 level
or even lg v40 level on a good day
nothing to write home about at this
point
so the camera can also as you imagine
capture more for view content both on
the back with the dual cameras or even a
four view selfie with the front-facing
array so really red
cares a lot about this for view maybe to
a fault there is a whole solid inventory
of content shot for for view some
trailers and some cinematic footage and
stuff like that it's great for demos and
that's what i've been showing people and
there's also an entire app store filled
with apps and games that support the
holographic display mode
but if i'm looking at this right it
looks like there's only about 20 apps in
the whole store and while that probably
is necessary for delivering for view
content with the special mode to
hydrogen buyers i guess you can't do
through the play store
i guess it's fine it just looks weird
that you need a whole separate app store
and a whole separate content store just
for supporting for view like youtube
doesn't support for view for example and
as far as photos no other phone out
there can view four view photos either
uh but to see what other people with
hydrogens are shooting there's this app
that i actually like called holopix it's
kind of like an instagram but just for
the 3d or four view photos there's a lot
of cool stuff on here that people are
shooting but there's basically just a
couple hundred users at this point just
people with hydrogens i have four
followers on here so uh check me out but
as i've gone down through the list now
you've probably noticed there aren't
really a whole lot of overwhelmingly
positive things to say
about this
1295 dollar phone as it exists right now
the one and only upside that i could
possibly think of
to save this phone and actually what
makes it so frustrating
is
red what i didn't talk about or
mentioned even at all in this video is
the pins down here at the bottom of the
back of the phone these exposed pin
arrays similar to what we've seen on
like moto phones as they've experimented
with modularity
are a sort of an unlockable key that
hasn't been turned yet at the bottom of
red site they have a whole section about
modules expandable storage
camera module and power pack modules all
coming in 2019. so you can see you know
a power pack module for extra battery
life on the already huge battery or an
expandable storage module for adding
even more storage again pretty simple
or the camera module
the cinema module which would be adding
a custom red made sensor
and an interchangeable lens mount
which would turn this
that that's what we want that would make
this the red camera in your pocket that
we are originally excited about from top
to bottom red silicon interchangeable
lens mount smartphone form factor
that would totally level up this device
but as of right now that's just a
complete fantasy that just exists in the
text on that page
for now i even asked jim about this as
well and he just confirmed what it
already says on the site which is just
2019
sometime in 2019. i think
i think there's really basically just
two ways to think about this phone
depending on how you feel about red this
phone is either
an overpriced total flop with last
year's specs and some gimmicky 3d
or
this is some revolutionary upcoming
modular device somewhere between a
smartphone and a portable cinema camera
with this virtual reality mode to it all
wrapped in one thing
you probably already know which side you
stand on as of right now there's
honestly no way to recommend this phone
for 1300
like imagine this phone without red
attached to it at all without the red
label or the red name on it
this is
at that point just some hopeless like
random android phone probably a 400
device uh with no hope of ever getting
modules
but with red behind it if you trust red
if you respect red and you think they're
going to stay behind this then this
could be a really interesting device in
the next year the only redeeming quality
is the potential for future improvement
if you trust red man i wanted this phone
to be so good and parts of it are pretty
good but as a complete package there's
only a tiny sliver of people i could say
should actually buy it as is and even
those people should probably wait and
save your money so i'll be waiting for
the modules
or hydrogen 2 whichever comes first
either way that's been it thanks for
watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace